hello this is presh talwalkar
here are four tips for winning your ncaa
bracket
play the odds work backwards use game
theory and beware of expert predictions
tip one play the odds
imagine you win 60 of the time if you
pick right
how would you pick 10 times in a row
yale students would pick a sequence of
choices left and right randomly in an
attempt to be perfect
they had a 52 percent success rate
rats by comparison simply picked the
favorite choice of right every time
they had a 60 success rate and therefore
they outsmarted the yale students
the lesson is don't overthink it you
should consider playing more of the
favorites to play the odds
tip 2 work backwards
the ncaa tournament has 64 teams which
means you need to pick 63 games
that's a lot of decisions so just as you
would solve a maze by looking at the end
and going to the beginning
you can solve your bracket
by considering picking your final four
picks first this will give you the most
impact and will trim the number of
decisions you have to make
tip three
use game theory
would you rather have an eighty percent
chance of splitting a hundred dollar
prize seven ways or twenty percent
chance
of having the hundred dollar prize to
yourself
the twenty percent chance of having the
price to yourself
will give you the most expected winnings
and that's the lesson you should try and
maximize your expected winnings it's not
about winning your bracket with the
highest percentage but rather when you
win
you will also have a chance of getting
the most money
game theory suggests you should be
contrarian to everyone else if everyone
else is playing the favorites you pick
the sleeper picks if everyone else is
picking the sleeper picks you should
pick the favorites
tip 4 beware of expert predictions
tv experts will often say that a couple
of made shots means a player is the hot
hand and a couple of missed free throws
means they lack the clutch gene
tv experts don't always know what
they're doing relative to the data
next thing the vegas line is not a
prediction of what will happen
it's a prediction of where the money bet
on both sides will be roughly equal
this is close to a prediction of the
game but it's not always the same
the third information source prediction
sites are always backwards looking
if there's a rule change like the one
and done phenomenon they're not going to
be able to take that into account as
quickly
as they should because they're using
historical data
you can read more about all of this on
my website mind your decisions the post
has a lot of details and links to useful
resources
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can get my
books listed on my website
catch me on my blog mind your decisions
follow mind your decisions on facebook
and google plus
follow me at preshtalwalker on twitter
instagram and tumblr and if you like
what i'm doing you can support me on
patreon